this wound alhamdulillah assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you I'm Eddie your
host and you're watching the Dean show
we're here on can TV 36 wednesdays at
midnight and if you miss us wednesday's
the following day thursdays at two p.m.
now we're going to be talking about
something there's some confusion out
there we know that design indicates a
designer that there is an Orchestrator
behind this universe and everything in
it and when you bring the definition of
God who he is it has to be simple it can
be confusing it can't have any ambiguity
in it and we have learned that this
creator has sent messengers throughout
time and they've all come with the same
message submit to the One God worship
Him alone your two-year-old can
understand that it's very simple we come
back we're going to help clear up some
of the confusion somehow this word
Trinity got in the mix somehow the one
God some people try to split them up
like a pie make them into three not
three but one I'm already getting
confused and i think i can add now when
we come back our intention is not to
hurt anybody's feelings our intention is
to clear up the confusion and to deliver
the truth so you want to go know we'll
be right back to clear up the confusion
here in a den show love there's only one
but Muhammad is His Messenger
I love like you love love love
ha there's only one where Jesus was his
messenger Allah why did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice and
we're back here in adentro and our guest
today come on my brother and your
brother how are you el mekki and hung
did not like how's it going hello an
external the love ok you're back in
Chicago loving in here you've been here
before the weather's great yeah been
here many times before yeah so we have
we've had you on the show before people
can go to the Dean show calm you have
your own section there and they can view
some of the past shows that we've
covered now you heard me introduce the
topic about the create or about the
confusion God is not the author of
confusion he makes things simple human
beings make it complicated so we want to
kind of try to unravel things and bring
things back to their pure state we don't
want to have fun nobody greatest want to
deliver the truth we're going to kick it
off with this Trinity what happened here
we're just come from excellent bristow
bismillah not a man hamdullah also at
work said I'm re enough I want to first
start by just relaying now a story of
something that happened when i visited
thailand now when i visited thailand i
was about seven or eight years old
alright so now i'm not trying to be
funny i'm not trying to be a wise go and
i tell you this story so this is just
basically the the observations of an
eight or a seven year old that can't
even recall how old I was at the time
and I had my siblings brothers and
sisters with ya every store you enter in
Thailand or how or shop you find they
have a small statue of with their God
and they put food in front of the statue
and then because it was summer the food
would dry up to the throw it away they
put new fresh food this might happen
twice three or four times a day
depending on what they put how it dries
up and they do it again the next day of
a number of times a day they keep doing
it multiple times per day for many many
years so some of them for 50 60 years
have been changing the food for the idol
for the god for so long now this the
observation of a seven or eight year old
we used to
me and with my brothers and sisters we'd
look at them and we'd laugh we would say
don't they realize that he hasn't ever
eaten don't they ask him when you take
the dry food away you know you haven't
taken a bite in the last 40 or 50 years
this is what we were saying back then
it's not because now this is my point
behind the story it's not because the
seven or eight year old was smarter than
the 60 year old who is constantly
changing the food for his entire life
it's simply that the seven or eight year
old was viewing the incident from
outside of what we call the box because
the person changing the food is inside
the box the box is a frame of mind a
thought process you believe certain
things about it and because you look at
it from within the box you don't see
what's wrong with it you see now let me
take the viewers to something that they
might have looked at from outside of a
box on the Discovery Channel they
there's a clip where there's this man
taking care of a temple where there it
has thousands and thousands of rats in
India and basically he believes
obviously these are reincarnated souls
and so on and so forth so he feeds them
and he sits on the floor and you've
probably seen the clip these rats are
all over his head and shoulder and then
just thousands of rats now because he is
inside the box he sees himself taking
care of the soles of his reincarnated
you know I don't know what you call them
brothers sisters what have you but
because we view it on the Discovery
Channel outside of the box to be honest
and I'm again I'm not trying to be funny
we just see a guy with a bunch of rats
on his head let's be honest yeah because
we're viewing the incident from outside
of the ball outside the box there was
one of the Companions of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu said lemme Allah
sent his piece of blessings and extol
upon him he his name was humbling jumuah
and he had an idol and the first thing
he would wake up in the morning he would
go to this God made of wood and he would
pray to it his sons became Muslims and
they wanted him to see that this is just
a wooden statue so the first day they
woke up early and they throw it in the
trash so he was really upset and he
swore if I found who did this to the
idol I know hurt them and do this and
that to them so he brought it washed it
boiled it and put it in the
place again the second one may woke up
before I'm they throw in the trash again
so he was so irate he said if I find out
who's doing this to you I will destroy
them third morning or third and third
day they took it and threw it in the
dump one nursing says they tied it to
the carcass of a dead dog so he went
looking for the god again and this is a
god that's supposed to bring him good
push away harm from him he saw it in the
dump tied to the carcass of a dead dog
he looked at it he said if you and
actually the second night what happened
he put a sword he hung a sword over the
neck of the statue of this God and said
if they come to throw you in the trash
defend yourself yeah third day you find
it attached to the body of a dead dog he
looks at it and he says by Allah if you
could defend if you could do any good
for your own cell if you could do any
good you would have defended your own
self you would have done good for your
own self push time from your own self if
you can't do it for your own self how
can you do it for me what happened in
this story is that his sons got him to
step outside of the box I don't know if
you paint or you draw and but when you
draw they teach you to step back from
your painting or from what you're
drawing yeah just to get another look at
it because sometimes when you're looking
at something from up close it's crooked
but you can't see it like when you write
on a blackboard your line is crooked but
you can't see when you're up close so
when you step away now you can really
see very clearly yeah so this is what we
need people to do people need to step
outside of the box for a moment and look
again take another critical unbiased and
an inlet analytical look at what they're
doing and what they believe in does does
it make sense when you step out of the
box and now this is this is the
introduction before we start talking
about the Trinity because the Trinity as
much as some people on earth firmly and
strongly believe in it they are there I
believe actually nobody really
understands how it works the concept of
something three things that are one even
though they are physically separate
items and we don't have anything on
earth that can be described in that
similar manner so what happens is
sometimes people need to just take a
pause and step back and look at them and
what they're believing in does it make
sense when you take a step back or not
we did this one time we
had a discussion with five missionaries
and they were in charge of teaching
bible study at our university in
virginia yeah and we started by getting
them to think outside of the box so we
asked a simple question the question was
is the trinity three and one or one and
three and basically were five
missionaries and they were teaching
bible study they should know the Bible
very well but they were quiet they were
all looking down and thinking was it 3
and 1 or 1 and 3 and I let them keep
thinking they kept thinking and kept
thinking and kept thinking and in the
end I had to give him the answer I said
obviously you believe it's three and one
because if you say one in three you're
admitting to worshiping three gods
suddenly all of them start saying yes
maybe you're right you're right yes
absolutely you're right expound on that
for a second how did you clarify this
how do they worship three gods if they
said warnings because if they say we
worship one God who is in three
different places they're admitting to
one two three different gods the easier
thing is to say we have three God heads
but the old one and they unite is one
yeah if you end with this new word one
you still have one God but he end with
the word here you're 18 3 yeah yeah but
why would they they know this most
Christians know it's three and one
everyone knows this about Trinity but
they were thinking for so long because
they never considered what one in three
men they never thought of that so that
got them to step outside of the box a
second question we asked again gotten to
think about this from in a way they
never looked at it before we asked him
this that there are three God's God the
Father this is back when Jesus was on
earth so according to you God the Son on
earth got the spirit wherever the spirit
was then God the Son dies for three days
during those three days how many gods
were there that would be Jesus peace be
yes the Sun so accordingly yeah so when
Jesus died for three days the third God
had according to them how many gods were
there so now you either have to say to
because 3 minus 1 is 2 or you have to
instill insist on one which means 1 plus
1 plus 1 is 1 and 1 plus 1 is still one
yeah or you have to say to so this
the problem so we asked him this
question and it was difficult for them
to answer because they never considered
that what does that mean and then some
started to say well he went up somewhere
else and but then but then the gospel
said that he had died for three days you
know that he will be resurrected on the
third day and so on and so forth so it
caused a problem and it got people to
think outside of the box how could this
be that one plus one plus one is 1 and 1
plus 1 is still one and as one person
tried to be a little crafty he said well
1 times 1 times 1 equals 1 what do you
say it is along with what we say to it
is that when you're adding three
different things you don't multiply by
one if i give you you know three
100-dollar bills you're not going to say
one times one thing that's one hundred
dollars on the table because if that's
the case I want to do business with you
I want to borrow a lot of money from you
and I'm going to give it back to you
using your logic see we don't accept
this kind of logic when it comes to
things in this life so why do we accept
this kind of explanation when it cooked
when it applies to the Creator you see
so then I'll tell you a time I sat down
with someone and he was a very honest
man I asked him very quickly look how
does this Trinity thing work and he was
a very honest man he said look nobody
really knows how it works he was
actually a pastor ahead of his church
and he said nobody really knows how it
works so then the next question was why
why would Allah reveal something that
you can't understand and link it to your
salvation say it again why would why
would God the crater that have is an
error reveal something to you that you
can't understand which is Trinity yeah
and Link Trinity to your salvation let's
hold it right there I'm going to take a
break and then you're going to tell us
to us to start with very right you have
to praise as if everything depends on a
lot it does
but you must work everything depends on
you and it doesn't that's my point you
see the same and I don't like that I
don't like us sitting here what are you
waiting for what are we waiting for
right now what do you wait for all these
people that come to this nah what are
you waiting for what are we waiting for
right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come along and bring these
people la sao paulo wanna put in our
hand the ability to do it now do your
job
back here on the Dean show let's
continue on right from where we left off
why would the creator of the heavens and
earth Allah go ahead okay and I just
want to preface this by saying that I
know I'm not trying to be insulting to
anyone i'm gonna give you actual
discussions that I've had with pastors
and people who are like either they were
missionaries or people who teach you
know bible study or they were heads of
churches real situations yeah half with
real people he's a real situation not
anything where we're trying to ridicule
another faith because in Islam were
commanded to obey up to like respect all
religions and respect to followers of
all other faiths so we're not trying to
be fine in here not trying to make fun
of anybody this is an actual discussion
that happened I asked the man he's the
head of his church okay how does the
Trinity thing work he said no one really
knows how it works so it's but but yet
believing in Trinity is linked to your
salvation so I asked him why would God
reveal something that you can't
understand and then link it to your
salvation that's like me telling you hey
Eddie you know what I've got some
funding for you too so you can do you
know your show and everything is twenty
thousand dollars but you need to
levitate in the air for half an hour
doesn't make sure like it you can't do
it so why would I give you the reward or
link your reward to something you can't
do why would God link your salvation to
a concept that nobody understands nobody
understands it and this is a pastor tell
I mean no one understands it really and
we can truly explain it but now if they
come with these explanations about the
egg and the yolk the water and all these
other things that people might come up
there they're all analogies that once we
like look at the egg basically saying
that the egg is composed of three
ingredients but it's one egg yeah but
that the problem is that when you
physically separate the ingredients it's
not an egg anymore you know if you see
the white on the floor you're not going
to think that's that's you won't know
what it is actually so it's not cold an
egg so the same thing that the triune
gods were physically separate so you
can't call them one they're not even in
one location you know what about the
water with the water ice yeah that it's
solid liquid gas or ice liquid and yeah
and get in vapor and but the problem is
again this is an example of one and
three not three and one yeah as we had
agreed that so
three in one so you can't give an
example of one in three water which is
one thing in three different states to
explain one in three in one it doesn't
it doesn't work out yeah so what you
might ask well there are many things we
don't know about God I mean we don't
know everything about God so why can't
we not know about the Trinity no because
20 is linked to your salvation take an
example now in Islam in Islam you'll
find the things that are essential to
your going to Paradise are very easy to
understand right for example one of the
things that I find it like quite
complicated in Islam is Islamic finance
okay I don't know if you ever looked
into quite a very tricky very
complicated very intricate imagine to
get to paradise in Islam yet to
understand the Islamic finance that
would be a nightmare yeah try those
would be empty but to get the paradise
you have to understand a very easy
simple concept like you said an injured
introduction a two-year-old can
understand it there is one God that's it
that's it hey do we need night night
classes for that that's it there's one
God that's the end of the story we don't
need to explain anything any other
number you need to explain how they're
to how they're three how they're seven
you need an explanation but one God you
don't need an explanation for them so it
can't be that well we don't understand
many things about God therefore Trinity
is one of those things no Trinity is
linked to your salvation it has to be
easy to comprehend the simple man in the
street has to be able to understand the
message that is linked to his or her
salvation so so then he he did kind of
start to go down the route were saying
you know well it's actually a mystery
you know it's very mysterious and god
works in mysterious ways and as you
quoted earlier you know it says in the
Bible that God is not the author of
confusion so where would this mystery
come from if God didn't author the
confusion and so just by asking these
questions now the man was beginning to
see to step outside of the box you know
and see that this can't be the case and
I actually asked him a question and
again I'm trying to I'm going to try to
quote exactly what I said them and what
he said to me I to I asked him I'm not
asking you which one you prefer which
one you like more which one you love I'm
asking you which makes more sense to you
the concept of God in Islam that there's
only one God that's where they worship
he has
Oh partner no children no relatives
nobody gives birth to him and he doesn't
give birth to anyone or the concept of
God in Christianity the triune God
specifically who is three and physical
different physical locations but is
still one one of them dies instead of
becoming too there's still one which is
easier to comprehend and I quote the man
the pastor of the leader of his church
he said the one that is more
intellectually satisfying is the Islamic
version how did he continue on that path
of worshipping God as three parts but
one in the Trinity or did he come around
to accept me no he continued he's the
body why do people just continue to do
this is more based off emotion and just
have it now it yeah it's a lot of things
like sometimes and I've actually met
people who said yeah I like what you're
saying and it makes more sense to me and
I'm more comfortable with it but this is
who I am or this is what my parents were
and I can't and I'm comfortable this way
you know many people don't want to leave
the comfort zone many times people know
that it's better for them to stop doing
something and they continue let's take
the easiest example of smokers yeah they
know they should stop but they keep
going yeah so it applies and it can be
this is a really good example I had
actually a situation where the gentleman
before I can finish the sentence he's
basically finished it for me that he
knows that it killed so many people he
knows he actually said that he went to
the class and he saw the the lungs at
their worst point where his black and
even the professor who was teaching a
class went outside with him did you have
a smoke Wow after all that all that so
so sometimes there are many different
things that pull on the individual to
not make the change even if they feel
this is the right chain you know and
like I said there are thousand one
different reasons so that's you think
that's one of the main one is just now
it's Who I am this is what I do it just
gotta do it for some people also you
cannot offset 50 years of belief with 10
minutes of explanation albeit even if
it's excellent explanation you can't
offset 50 years of what I used to be so
and in the end you know ultimate the
ultimat the guidance is in the hands of
al of course continue are giving us some
some more
examples we'll be right back I just want
to say very simple massive is the main
Tina one of the beautiful things about
our religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual and prayer who God
directly there is no intermediary the
lights will go on after the party and
the party will end it's very simple and
very clear there are no superstitious
rituals no strange incantations the time
is running out and we might not make it
to tomorrow and this is something that
we need to think about so have you
spoken to other people this was a
minister or a deacon or this person that
you were talking yeah yeah he was like
he was there the pastor of his church
yeah there was another time and again
i'm going to try the only quote actual
things that happened to me personally so
that no one thinks other we're making
things up or trying to be insulting me
anything one time and this discussion
happened over there the radio is a live
one on this show and and i called in to
the show and a minister called in to the
show and basically my argument was that
you know jesus actually was not divine
was not a god he never said he was all
right he never said he was and and this
is what we tell people look go by the
red letter bible you you're familiar
with us is a regular bible but
everything spoken by Jesus is in red ink
okay go buy it it's not very expensive
just go buy the red letter bible come
home read the letters in read-only
you're saying this on the radio so now
yes I studies on radio show and I'm
saying it right now to the viewers go
and read the red letters only what Jesus
said and just close the book don't look
what anybody else said did do you walk
away with Jesus telling you I'm God you
need to worship Me I'm divine you don't
you only get that message from other
people hinting towards it or explicit or
explicitly saying it but when you look
at the message of Jesus the Jews sent
priests and Levites tomorrow and when
they ask them you know what is the first
commandment he repeated word for word
with Moses said before him hear o Israel
the Lord our God is one Lord does he
ever once say people you need to bow
down kneel and worship Me
he said and worship the father who is in
heaven the woman called him good teacher
he says why do you call me good it is
only the father who was good so he's and
in his many times you say my father who
has sent me go to Bible calm and look
for those words sent my father sent me
and see how many times he says I was
sent just like all the profits that were
sent with a message he gave many
lectures speeches he preached the sermon
of the mount many of these famous like
speeches and he taught in people's homes
along the roadsides how come not once
does he clearly say listen people
clearly and explicitly I am God you need
to worship me I'm the third Godhead what
do I have today Eddie we have hints to
the triune God we have things that say
well this is an indication that Jesus
was God but look that's not acceptable
let's be realistic now what about the
word Trinity is it in the Bible the word
Trinity is not in the Bible but I'm
willing to let that argument slide okay
they might say well the word Trinity is
not in the Bible but they're hinged to
the Trinity look hint a hint is not
acceptable suppose now I give you a book
all right that says you know learn
French and 30 days you read the whole
book there is nothing about French does
that make sense to you the cover says
French yeah you read the whole thing
there's nothing about French if Jesus
was the son of God sent to divert
people's sins and he should be
worshipped he would have made that
message very very clear there's no way
that you would sit with him and listen
to his lectures and not walk away with
that message very clearly yeah you think
you would hint to that so it doesn't
make sense you're dying now and you need
someone to save you you're not going to
hit that you need help you're going to
scream out he'll definitely it doesn't
mean and the guy who is there the
lifeguard of the Coast Guard he's not
going to hint that his son fisherman
he's going to say look out we're here
and this is our job to help you so he
wouldn't hint or with all these sermons
he's just hinting to Trinity that's not
accept this is salvation this is our the
more important most important thing the
most important message can't be a hint
can't be vague and it can't be a mystery
and so that's what we were saying that
it cannot be that you look throughout
the whole Bible not once and underline
the words clearly and explicitly does
Jesus say look I need to be worshipped
I'm the third Godhead so what do we have
hint towards something of the divinity
of Jesus but like I said hints are not
acceptable so you have things like I am
the word or I and the father are one or
in the beginning or there were three
there are three that bear record in
heaven like this is the beginning of the
gospel of john which the footnote tells
you was added in the 16th century so
this is so this is a lot of times people
use well there were three that bear
record in heaven but this was added you
look at the footnote it's not a secret
it was added later on I mean quite
recently actually so it can't be that
the most important message is never
clearly spoken about it's just
impossible use not there's not a
textbook on earth that says on the cover
this is what I'm about and you read the
whole thing you can't find it clearly it
has to be clear how do you how do you
type we won't go into specifics because
we don't have that much time but for the
people who will come adamantly and
passionately and full of emotion and
zeal and they'll quote a doesn't half a
dozen verses and they'll try to justify
the Trinity it's so interesting really
that as as much whatever is quoted you
can quote something similar as a similar
like passage or a description about
someone besides Jesus but here they
won't take it literally for example John
three sixteen right the god or jesus
being God's only begotten Son very
popular verse so the word begotten here
is what sets him apart from anyone else
being because you know the believers are
children of God right according to the
Gospel of John but here the begotten Son
is what makes him separate and apart
from everyone else yeah but we haven't
in Psalms chapter 2 verse 6 God speaks
directly directly to David and he says
you are my son this day I have begotten
thee now people don't take this literal
we have the word begotten hear spoken
directly from God to David and yet
people don't see him as one of the sons
of God they don't take it literally hear
ya but here they do but but that's not
fair and that's not how it works this is
a really good example I mean what do you
say to this now what is an excuse that
someone will give you why they take it
literally in for Jesus peace be upon
them but here they don't because what
they do is they try to attach it to
others thing
that were said by Jesus let going back
to the story of the the minister that
called in on the show he said jesus
clearly said I am God because jesus said
I am the word and so they were everyone
was quiet so then he had to explain how
this means I'm God he says when you go
to Genesis so now this is 900 pages
earlier in the Old Testament so you
gotta somehow linked it you got a link
so you got to go all the way back to the
old testament to Genesis the first book
then it says in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and Jesus
now said I'm the word that means that's
him he was with God so that asked him a
question said listen and again I'm
telling you exactly what I told the man
I said I'm going to take the Bible right
now and go out into the street and talk
to people who are Christian okay maybe
they're not very knowledgeable about the
Bible are well versed but I'm going to
open it to that page and show everyone
in the street look Jesus said I'm the
word what do you get from that what do
you think the average person industry
will understand from I am the word oh
that means Jesus was a third Godhead and
he needs to be worshiped you can't get
all that information with this until you
make the 900-page jump to the beginning
and force it into that link for sir
force it and that's why when you tell
him David was a big art & Son of God
they don't link it be but they forced
any other link because they because the
mindset is to believe the frame of mine
is that Jesus was the big out and sort
of God so even if there's something
hinting to anything they will look at it
that way for example where it says I and
the father are one now what does that
mean one in purpose or one literally
obviously is not literal because the
father's in the heavens and he was on
earth so what does it mean or when he
says I am there's no way to the Father
except through me you know as a Muslim
that makes perfect sense to you yeah
jesus said the only way to the father is
through me it makes perfect sense if God
sent a prophet to earth to guide you are
you going to bypass him and find your
way to god no and bypass that prophet
it's got to be through him he was sent
to guide you that's all it means but
when when you're in the mindset of
believing Jesus was the son of God
everything that hints to it you will
take it as such tell us now we had said
earlier that
sincerely we want to deliver the truth
we're not trying to step on our toes
nobody hurt nobody's feelings now that
somebody is being sincere open-minded
humble heart and they say you know what
this man makes sense it looks at his
wife the wife or the husband say hey
this is making sense what do they do now
deliver but you you know what where do
they go from here talk to us deliver the
true concept of God and some advice to
him thanks Allah first of all I do want
to say that the the message of one God
is extremely consistent throughout the
Bible old and new Testament included in
the Old Testament so many times he will
talk about or God will warn people of
taking other others and worship besides
him all the prophets would tell people
to worship one god only god at court in
the Old Testament says I am your Lord
besides me there is no God suddenly in
the New Testament we discover that there
are three supposedly now this actually
is a jump in a diversion from what we
have learnt been learning all these
thousands of years of the prophets
saying there's one God only there's no
other God you the Lord their God is one
Lord suddenly we hear three but then
Jesus himself didn't say there's three
he said worship the father he should
worship God he tells me what the worship
God he said there's only one Lord same
thing that the Jesus that Moses said
before him so what happens now is you're
starting to see the consistent message
of all the prophets that pie God this
consistent message of Jesus read the red
letters don't take my word for it and
this is the message of the Prophet that
came after Jesus as well the prophet
mohamed salah salem in Arabia who also
came and called people to worship only
one God who has no partner who has no
children who has no relatives or
anything of that sort nobody gives birth
to him and he does not give birth and
also didn't change the basic message of
the Ten Commandments and everything
stays consists oh you're actually
following what would be the true message
of Jesus by accepting the message of his
brother and prophet muhammad sallallahu
ala who said no thank you very much
they're being a fuss and helping to make
these things very clear
I'm very simple one God and we cleared
up the confusion about the Trinities
nowhere in the Bible and the messengers
taught it neither did Jesus peace be
upon him who is so beloved to our hearts
he is a mighty messenger he's not a son
of God he's not God but he is one who
taught the people the same way Moses did
in Abraham and the last and final
message sent to mankind they taught the
same message submit to the One God
submit your entire self to his will not
you will in simple English do what God
wants you to do on his terms we'll see
you next time tune in every week to the
Dean show we're here at the same time
same Channel until then Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you no speech is better
than to do that would call people to
Allah and to do there were no speech is
better you know nothing is better than
that is it true that if one person I'm
the Allah giving you an ability to guide
so much the lost permission the greatest
permission that is better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
giving job and this is something that we
encourage all the msa's all the dowel
organizations the mustards forget this
we want to threaten or we give these to
the novices for free for free for free
we want our brothers it eats combed
Italy everybody sleeping I arise and ask
a lot of thinking me Omar you see all
are you know all the sins I do I turn to
you to forgive my sin tomorrow
I'm missing for slave yo my love alone
I'm the one runs away all the guide me